- Now that I'm in it, it
just makes me so excited
because there's been so many influences
to steer me away from being
where I'm at right now.
Like my parents don't
agree with it at all,
I get called a whore and
a slut and I get told
that I'm gonna be on crack
by the time I get here.
And it's so hard because
these are my parents
telling me these things.
And all my friends are really supportive.
They're like, "As long as you're safe,
"as long as it's everything
good and you're happy,
"that's all I want."
And I'm like, "Uh."
- [Interviewer] Okay, Raven.
- [Raven] Yes.
- [Interviewer] Raven,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I grew up in a small town
of 4,000 in Sacramento area.
It's like an hour away from Tahoe,
so just completely nature
and surrounded by trees.
And I've lived there my whole life
and just kind of move around
the area, just never left it.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- Yes, I have both my parents
but they were not really together
I wanna say for a long time of my life
just because they would
argue and they would fight
then they would break up
and get back together,
and break up and get back together.
And I would stay with my
grandparents, which were more
like my parents and my uncles and my aunts
since I would just be
surrounded by them 24/7.
And that's where they
got married around 2008
but still had those arguments.
So they are together just not stably.
- [Interviewer] So what was the reason
that you were raised
mostly by your grandpa?
- My parents started out as alcoholics
and they got a little tangled in drugs.
Right when I was born, my
mother had just stopped alcohol
when she found out she
was pregnant with me,
like she just quit
drugs when she found out
that she was pregnant and sort
of had me with a trauma bond,
instead of really bonding with me.
And after I was born,
she did take care of me
but then she just started working,
she started drinking
again and my eldest sister
and my second eldest sister
became sort of my parents
as well when they were home from school
or staying home from school.
- [Interviewer] So how would
you describe your childhood?
- Eventful. (chuckles)
Very eventful and very traumatic.
That's a good one, but it's very eventful.
There's lots of really good moments
but they're just weighed
down by everything else.
Like I got diagnosed with CPTSD
which is a complex
post-traumatic stress disorder
just because every single year of my life
I've never not had something traumatic
like either every month
or like every other month.
So I've just gotten so desensitized
to a lot of traumatic things
and I've grown to pain,
but it was very eventful, at least for me.
And I don't know about my other siblings
but I know we can talk
about it a little bit
and share traumas and
know that we're not crazy.
- [Interviewer] What kind of trauma...
What kind of things did you go through?
- One, my sister went
through when I was one
that she told me that we
just actually bonded over
is my mom was on a drunken
rage, I was one years old,
she had me in her arms in
the bathroom barricading it
'cause my own mom wanted
to attack me and her.
And I was the only one.
Other instances are like my
parents would just get so drunk
and just get to the point where
you're angry or irritable,
you're puking, and you should go to bed,
but they would stay up
and just start arguments.
We'd have to have the
cops called so many times
for domestic abuse.
And it's like I'd have to go to my nana's,
which would be like everything.
But one night for me specifically
that I just distinctly remember
is I was like two or three,
maybe four at the max,
and my mom and dad got into a huge fight.
It wasn't even dark out yet,
it was about like 5:00,
6:00 in the summer.
And she was drunk and
crying in her back room
and there were guns back there
and I had police officers
actually use me as bait to get her out
'cause she was threatening
to kill herself.
And at the time, I was like, oh my gosh,
my mom's gonna hurt
herself, I need to save her,
and that's like a
three-year-old would think
'cause I didn't really think past it.
I had to be bait, I had
cops behind me waiting
and just in case, they had guns ready
if she were trying to
shoot me, I had no clue.
And I finally got her out and
then I put her in handcuffs
and by that age I was
like, I arrested my mom.
That was just such a
traumatic change for me,
and at least in school, before
I even went into full school,
there was just such this different person
by the time I got there.
So it's like I used to be
this really fun, bubbly,
energetic kid, and then by age five,
I was already independent, I
just wanted to go to school,
go home and sleep.
Or at least play with
toys and dissociate from
whatever's going on.
- [Interviewer] That's
a lot to go through.
So no sexual abuse or anything like that?
- Unfortunately, I did
go through sexual abuse.
I had gone through a lot of therapy
and I've just actually
been open to getting it,
and willing to at least just because
I've had so many eventful
things and going after therapy
is so good, therapy is
great, I always promote it.
But it is heavy when you
realize parts of your traumahood
that you couldn't really remember before,
and now you're remembering them.
My uncle, when I was
younger would always...
I was so into technology and games.
He would show me his game
boards, all old GameCube
and everything, and then the computer.
And one day I happened to
just see a lewd picture
of an anime girl who had bigger breasts
and she was wearing
something skimpy and cute.
And I didn't think anything
of it 'cause it was like,
whoa, that's kind of like
Pokemon or something like that.
And I was really heavily
into Japanese cartoon
so I was really interested.
But one day I just remember
watching anime porn
and I didn't know that
(indistinct) I was watching it,
and I didn't know that what he was doing
was teaching me to masturbate
and he was touching me, and
it was so much just to
have in my head and going,
whoa, is this why I'm hypersexual?
This is why I'm like anime.
And it was a real life changer for me.
And I was like, do I
like any of these things
because I just got
traumatized and not like...
Really took a toll on me
'cause I had just started
the industry and I was
just here and I was like,
wow, is my whole life a lie?
But it really made me who I
was, but it did shape who I was
because after that it was different.
We had incidents at school with me
where I just would let people
touch me and do whatever.
And when it came down to it,
to like who taught you this?
I couldn't really say my uncle
and I didn't know how to do
it so I just blame myself.
Like I said I looked it up online.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
how old are you in this?
- At least five or six, I was
kindergarten or first grade.
And that's where another part
of me, somebody just said,
at least my nana said a
light in me just died.
And for years and years
she would always say,
"You know, I think he touched you."
And me being me I would just deny it
until I went through specific therapy.
It was such a game changer for me.
But it helped me get over a lot of things.
'Cause I was hypersexual and I
would let boyfriends abuse me
and sexually abused me and almost rape me
'cause I thought that was okay.
And actually coming into the industry
I've learned so many standards
people wouldn't think.
There's so many standards
and safety and consent
that comes with this
industry that the fantasy
may portray differently, but it is nothing
compared to what I've
actually been through
and then compared to like doing
a scene where they're like,
"Oh, are you okay?"
Compared to somebody
not caring what they do.
- [Interviewer] In the real world?
- Oh yeah, they just don't care.
They're like, "I didn't do it."
And you're like, "I saw you do
it and it's a straight face."
- [Interviewer] Whereas
in the porn industry
you're protected and-
- Oh yeah, I even say like, "Ow,"
like pretending and they're
like, "Wait stop, are you okay?"
And I'm like, wow, this
is so much different
than what people perceive it to be
and what I perceived
it, at least growing up.
But I got the worst
end of it in the actual
fantasy people want.
- [Interviewer] So you
went through high school?
- Yeah, I actually made
it through high school.
It was really rough for four years.
I went to Eldorado High School,
and that school is very harsh as it is.
It's known to be a druggy school
where all the stoners kids go
and all the depressed kids.
And Eldorado County has
just kind of a bad rep,
at least when I was going there.
There was a lot of drug abuse, a lot of
STDs were going around too
because we weren't
actually properly educated.
There was pregnancies
and we even found needles
in the bathroom at one point
in my sophomore year, I think.
But I was no better 'cause
I had pills fed to me.
My mother would give
me Norcos or Tylenol 3s
and even Percocets like oxycodone
as pain relief for my
headaches or something.
Instead of just going to a
neurologist that costs $300,
we would just get pills
for like two bucks.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think you were addicted?
- Oh, I was definitely addicted.
It was such a good feeling
just to like escape reality.
I still did my homework,
I still managed to
just be dependent for
awhile, for like two years.
I was obviously addicted
'cause I would be cranky
and I'd detox and withdraw
if I didn't have them.
But I at least managed to get
my studies and my focus done
and I made sure to
learn something at least
while I'm just messed up.
And by the time I started
experimenting with weed,
like my friend was like, "Here, try this."
I didn't even wanna do pills anymore.
I was like, "Whoa." I was like,
"this makes me feel better
"and I don't even wanna take it anymore."
I was like, "What is this?"
And then I would have family issues
because pills are prescribed
and safer than marijuana
which was getting legalized at the time
and was like almost fully legalized.
And it was just so hard
because at age 14, I had Norcos
and at age 14 my friends
were just starting with weed
or not even thinking about
drugs, maybe vaping at the most.
But my generation, at least
my class was very traumatized.
I at least knew the people
from my middle school
who were traumatized.
We were bullied, beat up by our
eighth graders all the time.
And the school really
didn't do a lot about it
until we were gonna leave and
we had anti-bullying talks
and like if we're having a rough
time at home, call someone,
and like going into high
school knowing that information
we still managed to get addicted to drugs.
And instead of telling
each other it's wrong,
we already knew what a bunch of each other
were going through.
And I did theater for four years.
It was the best experience of my life.
I got to do things like this
and one-on-ones with people,
I would never really talk to
somebody who has upperclassmen,
that's so popular, has
the same life as me.
And it's like, it was
such a good experience.
And I love Studio 81,
if I could donate so much money
to them, I would right now.
But just like, wait, get a savings.
That place really did save me a lot.
'Cause there were so many
people that were like me
but so different and hid
it just as well as me.
But I had that shame of abuse
'cause I didn't really know
it was abuse until, I think
I was a senior and I was sleeping
through most of my classes
and I even got kicked out,
well, taken from my home
'cause I had to call the cops on my mom
and still go to school the next day.
Like the same day go to school.
And it was so funny because
she was attacking me
'cause I wanted to leave,
it was getting too much.
I wanted to go to rehab and
get myself clean and just get
away from her 'cause she
was physically attacking me.
And so when I actually called
the cops, got out of the house
I started detoxing,
learning about other people
who's got it way worse than me,
but like still is in the same area as me.
And I got to actually learn
what my problems were,
how to get out.
But I got sidetracked by raving,
which I got to be med tent,
but I also fell into all
the drugs that raves do
enable you to have and
they're right there.
But once I started
messing with psychedelics,
I was like, this is a problem,
because you do get in your head.
And I was like, my body is skinny,
I'm losing weight, not gaining
it, pills are a problem.
And December 24th of 2019, I
just gave pills up cold turkey,
went through the whole detox,
went through everything.
And I was like, "I don't
wanna end up where my mom is."
She has four girls and all of
them are kind of questioning
how they messed up so much
when we didn't really do anything wrong.
We're a child, we're here just to learn
and we had to teach and learn ourselves.
- [Interviewer] So you're clean now?
- Oh yeah, I'm clean 100%.
I have on my phone these calendar,
like these clocks of days
of everything that I
stopped using what days,
and there's nothing under
100 right now, or even 170.
And I'm so excited about that
'cause it's such a hard thing
to talk about, is the shame of drug abuse.
And it's like, somebody
like me, they could probably
see me as a stoner, yeah, I
give off those vibes 100%,
but no one knew that I was
abusing Norcos and even Percosets
no one really knew that
my friend was doing lines,
she was snorting Xanax, and
she was doing lines like this,
and I would cut it in half
because she would overdose.
And it was really hard
because I had to give up
a whole friendship and
friend group to get sober
and to even help my friend get sober
'cause she was doing lines of coke.
And I almost overdosed in her
house just from half a line
she was doing, and she
was doing more than me.
And I didn't even do coke,
I was doing her Xanax lines.
So I was like, "Oh my gosh,"
I was like, "I can't do it."
And I even lost that friendship.
But it's like the whole drugs are just,
they affect you so
differently in the shame
just you never actually reach
out until you hit rock bottom.
But I've gone to NA meetings.
They've actually really saved a lot of,
they've wasted so much
of my time sometimes,
but it just gives me another
reason to want to help people
who are in those situations.
Like on my Twitter, I may have
like 1,000 followers already
but I'll still message people back.
I've had people say, "Hey, I'm
having a suicide problems."
I'm like, I don't care, Raven is here.
I'm still talking to you right here,
but if you want my personal
information, I'm here just
because I know how hard
it is not to have anyone,
especially like I had my nana and my mom,
but my nana would tell me straight,
and she passed away this
last June, or no July,
this last July of 2020.
So I haven't really had
her to help keep me going
or my mom, but my mom
was my enabler as well
and basically my supplier to all my drugs.
And it was really hard
when I stopped doing them
because they're right there,
I could still do them.
She has them in the house, but it's like-
- [Interviewer] And also using today?
- She uses Suboxone, which
is a lower form of opioid.
But to be honest, she
really does stockpile them
and doesn't use them or
she'll overuse one day
'cause she's in more pain and I'm like,
that's just the addiction
because you don't really need
all these boxes of drugs for
possible future outcomes,
that's just like the shame you have.
And we get into massive
arguments over it 'cause she says
that she's clean, she's doing
fine, but you're not clean
if you're still using
it and making excuses.
And it's so hard 'cause
I know my mom and I
will never have that
relationship that I really envy,
that everyone has.
Like I'll see TikToks of
people with their moms
and I'm like, man, if I
did TikToks people would be
really depressed and I'd go
viral for another reason.
And it's like I do have to
record my mom's arguments in mind
because she does invalidate
all my experiences I've had.
And I wouldn't be where I am
now if I didn't have them.
And everyone who has those relationships,
at least, even if they are drugged ones
and they have close
relationships with their family,
I really envy that just because I had that
with both of my grandmothers
and now they're gone.
And it's like so hard,
'cause people are like,
"I've lost my mother," and I'm like,
"Me too, but my biological
one's still alive."
And it's hard 'cause people
don't understand that.
But my eldest sister and
I have talked about it
and it's got like we
agree that we lost our mom
a long time ago.
And she's still trying to find herself
but we can't really help her with that.
And that's the hardest
part about at least me
'cause everyone's like, "Oh,
go talk to your mom," or this.
And I'm like, "Okay."
- [Interviewer] Change's a big
part of addiction, isn't it?
- It is.
I didn't go to my mom.
Even though she was the
one giving it to me,
I would go to my nana,
she was the only person
that had no shame on it.
But I never really went
to my friends for help
until I was like skinny, I
wasn't eating, I wasn't hungry.
I was detoxing completely,
I lost like 10 pounds,
and it just completely changed me.
And I was so shameful just to tell people,
"Yeah, I'm detoxing from drugs,"
until one day I just got
so fed up with people
expecting me to help them
and be in their lives.
And I'm like, I'm trying to
get my shit together myself.
I'm like, what am I supposed to do?
So I just told people, I'm like,
"Hey, I'm going through
this problem right now.
"I'm addicted to pills
and I can't help anyone
"until I help myself."
And it was at that moment
that I lost so many people.
So many people just
stopped being my friend.
They were like, "Oh, you're
no fun, you're a prude."
I'm like, "Yeah, I am,
I'll take it, I'm a prude."
But I got closer with so many
other people who were like,
"I actually wanna quit too
and I'm having a struggle."
And that's when I got this
really good group of friends
that I just acquired and
I'm working hard to keep
just because it's a lot of work.
And when I was on drugs, I just
didn't care if I had friends
I would talk to them like they
were my best friends ever,
but in reality, we had
no clue about each other.
And getting over that shame
really brought the real people,
the genuine friends that I have out.
And it just takes that like big step
of getting over your
own fears and boundaries
just because you're your own
worst enemy during those times.
- [Interviewer] So then at
some point you got to...
How old are you?
- I'm only 20.
- [Interviewer] You're 20.
So you've been through
a lot for a 20-year old.
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] And then you
got into porn at some point.
- I got into porn when I was 19.
Last year actually I was, for
the pandemic when that started
I got kicked out because my
mom listened to a conversation
and (chuckles) she
listened to me talking
about my past drug use
and me talking to someone
privately just about help.
And I was getting off the shame.
She kicked me out dramatically
and very traumatically.
And that is when I actually
started getting things together.
But then it was a pandemic.
So there's not a lot of things open,
everything was going down,
and I said, you know what?
I've been saying this since
I was young, if I have
no other option, why not be
a stripper or a porn star?
And I was just joking, but
I was serious at that point.
And I was like, you know
what, I'm really hypersexual.
I take pride in actually pleasing someone.
I've had an OnlyFans for a little bit
and I'm comfortable with it, I was like,
you know what, I'm gonna try it.
And so I just went on to
Pornhub out of everything
and I noticed there's like,
"Wanna join the talent, sign here."
And I clicked on one of them.
And in April I got just a call back
from Backroom Casting Couch.
And that's when they were like,
we would love to have you.
And I was just so shocked
that somebody was like,
"Yeah, your pictures that
you sent in were beautiful."
And I was like, you
know what, it's $2,000.
I didn't get a stimulus, I was a student.
I was like, I need this
money just to live.
And I was like, it'll help me out.
I was like, it's a one-time
thing, no contract signed.
I was like, and if I like it, I like it,
if I don't, never again.
And it ended up being
such an amazing thing.
They paid for my flights and everything,
which usually doesn't happen.
But it was just such
an amazing experience.
And just to get money
for actually doing work
and helping out and being genuine,
I was like, this is so amazing.
And during the pandemic,
it helped out so much
'cause I didn't have my parents,
I applied for loans and I
couldn't even get loans or grants.
I was working three jobs
and it was just right when
I did that, I was like, you
know, this might be something.
And I didn't think anything of it.
I kind of let my ego
get to it a little bit,
but then I got a call a week
later from the same people.
And they're like, "Hey,
we had someone cancel,
"would you like to do another shoot?
"This is a one-time thing,
we don't usually offer this."
And I was like, "Yes, let me take it."
I didn't even care about the
offer, I didn't even care,
I was like, "I will be there ASAP,"
I got on a plane the next morning.
And I was like, this is
something that I wanna do,
I like traveling, I like
having to actually keep
a good image on my body and
work harder for what I want.
Because yeah, I could pay for
someone to make me beautiful
but working hard for it
and having people be like,
you're genuinely beautiful
and hear it all the time,
at least in the industry really
gave me the confidence I needed.
And after my nana died few
months later, I was like,
I fell into a depression work-wise,
it was even worse for COVID,
and that's when I just get
a call and they were like,
"Do you wanna actually be in the industry,
"it's calming down, we can
get you in and do shoots."
And I went, "Yes," without a hesitation.
I started working up just
to drive down to L.A.,
and I actually ended up flying,
and it just became such
a good experience for me
just because I got to witness
what it would actually be like
and see if I could actually handle it.
And at first it was really scary
just to have all these cameras on me,
all these people looking at
me telling me how to pose,
telling me how to look
and not even knowing
what pictures would come
out, and having just
this little insecurity
that I've had for so long.
And it just all washed away.
And now that I'm in it, it
just makes me so excited.
'Cause there's been so many
influences to steer me away
from being where I'm at right now.
Like my parents don't
agree with it at all.
I get called a whore and
a slut, and I get told
that I'm gonna be on crack
by the time I get here.
And it's so hard because
these are my parents
telling me these things.
And all my friends are really supportive.
They're like, "As long as you're safe,
"as long as it's everything
good and you're happy,
"that's all I want."
And I'm like, "Aw."
I'm happy where I'm at,
I'm getting somewhere where I want to be,
and then it's like, I
let family overshadow
the actual people that are important.
And listening to people that are important
have really gotten me to where I am today.
And I'm not hesitant, I'm
really excited to wear...
Like I get a text about a
shoot and if I can't make it
just because I'm too far
away, I just get so excited
even if it's lower than
anything, even $100
just to like help out, it's so much fun.
And I wanna be just dive in
and in part of it, cause it's,
it gives me something more than
what I had a few years ago,
which was just drugs, trauma and pain.
- [Interviewer] So it's partially
a way to support yourself financially?
- Exactly.
- [Interviewer] But then also
there's the hypersexuality
you think from...
Does that come from what
happened with your uncle?
- I've sexually assaulted by many exes
and my own family member
and then like it's,
learning 'cause I was hypersexual
ever since that incident
and my parents never knew why.
And I've always wondered why I've had just
such a high sex drive,
and I've been so aware,
and I've been so into it
compared to everyone my age,
that this just makes it easy
to at least cope a little bit,
but also to get out of
the fear because I know
a lot of people who have
been sexually assaulted
or sexually abused do have that fear
whenever they're really
intimate with someone.
And I've had times where
I've cried afterwards
after somebody I've
really genuinely enjoyed
and I'm like, why am I crying?
And doing this really did help.
And it's not everyone's cup of tea,
there's other ways to
really get out of it,
but for me, this really
did help get over a lot of
stressors and anxieties that
I've had from past experiences.
And with that, it really did
help just kind of grow at least
and find out what I actually do like,
and not just to be having a
one-night stand with someone
who doesn't know anything
and they're really drunk
compared to someone who's
done this for years,
can actually help me find what I like,
is really sensitive to me
and I can actually talk
to people about that in the industry.
And a lot of people in the
industry can relate to me
and it's so sad, but it just
makes it even more welcoming
and it gives me standards to what I want
for when I am intimate with someone else
that it's not really my work.
- [Interviewer] Is there any
shame connected with this?
- There was.
There was at first when
I did my two first shoots
and I wasn't really with an agency.
There was a lot of shame because
I lost a few people for it,
and a lot of people started
fights over it with me,
and I'm like, this is my choice, my body,
unless you wanna pay my bills
for me, then by all means.
But I've tried to pay all
my bills all by myself.
I've had help from some
people during COVID,
but everything else I've
really worked hard for.
And the shame with this
part, I think the only shame
was just because I didn't have an agency
and my videos would be
there, and I would just not
make profit or have anything
besides my OnlyFans.
But then that's when I got a
call from Next Level Agency
I'm like, Oh my gosh.
I was like, they're a really good agency.
And that's when I just gave up the shame.
I was like, who cares?
If they're not paying my
bills then why should I care?
And they're not living my body,
they haven't gone through anything,
I would love for them to take
a day off in my shoes for me.
At least with me, the
shame was really easy
to just drop it out because
I'm in my natural body,
why should I really be ashamed of that?
And then with how drugs were,
there's just a different shame.
And once I got rid of
at least the porn shame,
the drug shame just
slipped off with it too
to where I can talk about
it openly and be like,
yep, I'm a recovering addict forever,
but at least I'm not an
active addict right now.
- [Interviewer] Is this the best part
in your life right now?
- This is the best
start because I'm ending
a lot of traumatic connections with people
and a lot of trauma bonds.
This is just the start to
something great since I am only 20
and I have no clue what's to come for me
for these next years,
but I know this is just
such an amazing start,
an amazing just like push
to where I want to go
just because I know I can't
physically do sex forever.
I'm really into cosmetology,
film and photography,
and I've actually been saving
up for school to do that
even though it's so
expensive in California.
And I've been trying to apply
to grants and everything
and still have something
else to do besides here,
since I do have, sometimes I have weeks
that I don't get shoots, so I'm just like,
what do I do during this time
that I can make flexible?
And it's like, all my hobbies that I like
are coming into one so I can do it.
And it's just such an amazing time.
Even though we're still in a pandemic,
it's like a really rough, harsh time,
but it's such a good time
to just start something new
and to grow it since
pretty much a lot of people
are at rock bottom right now.
And it's like, that's the best thing,
is you have a chance to
actually build something.
And if it doesn't work, it's okay,
you can start over, you're
already at rock bottom.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, tell
me about working in porn.
I mean, are you asked
to do things sometimes
that you're uncomfortable with?
- Yes.
And I can easily always say
no to that just because-
- [Interviewer] It's like there's a trend
to go towards the most
extreme sexual things
they can come up with.
- I'm really kinky and I've
been through a lot of abuse
so someone would be like,
"Yeah, you have a bruise,"
and I'd be like, "I don't even feel it."
And so my pain tolerance is
really high for a lot of things
that a lot of people would be like,
"Oh gosh, I couldn't get tied up."
I'm like, "I don't care.
"This is not as bad as
what I've been through."
And so that helps a lot with me.
But there have been times where
there's just been
miscommunication on what I like.
And there's usually like a tap signal
or a word that we say and we
just do the scene over again.
Or I've been offered bookings
for things that I'm not into,
and I just politely pass
them just because it's not
my cup of tea, but then
somebody else from my agency
might get it and do amazing
'cause they love it.
I know a lot of people are
like, "Oh, I'll be gay for pay."
And I'm like, "I'm bisexual,
I will be gay for pay,
"but I won't do anything
that's out of my comfort zone
"just to get paid"
I'll work harder somewhere
else, like on my OnlyFans
or something to make up
for something I missed.
Just because it's so open
and it's really consensual
for this industry.
I know a lot of people who've
been in different agencies
have said otherwise because
it's more of an escort
and not an actual professional agency.
And it just depends on the agency.
The industry itself is so good
but there's a lot of downfalls to it.
It just really depends
on where you put yourself
and if you find all the facts right.
But for me, it's been the
most consensual thing ever.
This is the best sex that I've had
just because it's so safe,
it's the safest sex I've had,
it's like fantasies I want to
do, I'm making money from it,
and I'm actually like
learning about myself.
So with all of that, and with my agency,
I have an amazing agency,
it just fits so perfectly.
But for other people,
they may have like a really bad industry,
like industry agency for the industry
and it can really mess with someone.
And I can see where there's
some points where it's like,
"Wow, this industry is really messed up."
But it's kind of like the
music industry as well,
it's harsh.
You don't always have to have connections
but if you have a good agency to help you,
it really does make a day go around.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So coming from the childhood that you had
and the struggles that you've had,
what are your insights into
coming from a background like that?
You have have a drug addict mom,
you had uncles that were touching you,
you had very little parental
guidance (indistinct)
like other than your grandmother.
- Oh gosh, it's just-
- [Interviewer] For a child to
go through that and just be-
- Turn out the way that I am right now.
- [Interviewer] Well, I mean,
you seem to be pretty good,
but you were a drug addict
and now you're working in porn
and you're 20 years old.
On paper that looks kind of like-
- Oh yeah, whenever I think about it
and just put it out flat without context,
it does seem like my life
has gone down spiral.
It's really hard just
because when I do tell people
I'm a recovering addict some people react
to hiding their pills
and being freaked out.
And it does hurt a little
bit, but that's who I am,
and that's what I did choose
'cause I was actively
taking it from my mom.
And like, even though I was
a minor and I didn't have
any form of stability or way
to actually take care of myself
until 17 when I started
a job, it's just...
The way you treat people to,
'cause people don't know me.
And some people will treat me
really rude, 'cause I'm tiny,
they think they can take
me, but I'm really like,
I'm such an aggressive person
and no one would think that.
But with all those years
of abuse, you have no idea
what's on the other side
when you look at someone.
You have no idea what's behind them,
you have no clue what
they've gone through,
and with me, I'm so open about it now.
But before I would just take it on people.
If someone would shove me, I
would either cry really hard
or I'd shove them back because
that's what I was taught at home.
And it took so many years to get over it.
And for people who have
no idea what it's like
to go through this, it's just
a lot of just mental hate.
It's just self hate because
a lot of my friends hate themselves
because their parents
just chose to do things.
And it's like, I hated myself
every year for Christmas
'cause I would want one
thing, maybe sort of expensive
but in the hundreds and my
parents would go all out
and make me feel so horrible
for wanting something.
And I know a lot of people went through
just taking it in and internalizing it
'cause that's what you're
supposed to do as children.
But when you become like 14, it comes out
and we don't fully realize that
since children don't really
need therapy, is they're happy,
and that's where it
came in to me, at least.
And looking back at it, I'm like,
I have had a rollercoaster of a ride.
I've tried to kill myself many of times
just because mentally it was too much
and being untreated for ADHD and CPTSD
and so many other things being
untreated, it was so much.
And without it, I would be
such a different person.
I'm so grateful I went through this
and possibly save someone else
from not going through this,
'cause there are so many
people that could not handle
where I'm at today.
And I don't think of myself as strong
'cause my arms are small and
I probably could get beat up
by literally anyone.
But I'm such a strong person
and everyone who has trauma
or abuse or has just anything
that can relate to me
can understand that you'll
get back up, you don't care.
We'll still get back up
'cause we've been used to it.
- [Interviewer] It makes you stronger.
- It really does.
And people don't realize
it because they just get
so in their head and
they just get so hateful
of all these things that
they couldn't control.
And for people who've
never gone through it,
it's just such...
It's so nice for me at
least to just see someone
not go through something.
And they're like, "Yeah,
my life was really good."
And I'm like, "That is amazing,
"I hope nothing happens to you
"cause it changes you forever."
And if you know someone who's
been sexually assaulted,
they will never be the same
person that they were before.
You just have a part of you taken out
that you have to deal
with that you don't like,
and it's just stuck with you forever.
And it's hard for people,
but at least for me,
I've learned just to accept it,
and that's the biggest thing. (laughs)
Oh, L.A..
But it's just like the biggest thing.
Especially in L.A., there's so
many people going through it
during COVID and it just
breaks my heart that
they may reach out or they may not
and they have to go through this.
And not enough people are
aware of the signs of people
going through stuff just because
we're so good at hiding it.
And as much as I love people
who don't go through this stuff
I just hate the ignorance
that sometimes comes
just of like, you have no clue
what that person has gone
through and it's been hell.
People have threatened to
beat me up and I've gone,
"My mother can probably do
better than you, I'm sorry."
Like you're nowhere
compared to where this woman
or like any of my exes could be.
And for people who just
don't go through it,
I just always recommend taking a step back
for some situations and always
thinking before you speak,
just because some people
really are not there
when they're going through
it and it's so hard
to not project when you've
just gone through something
or not shut down or go
into a depressive episode.
And it's like, these
things are so normal to me,
and when my friends go through it,
there'll be depressed on the couch.
I'll be cleaning their house
and I'll just be taking care
of them because I know it's
something that's normal.
And it's like the shame
that comes with it,
even people just go through something,
never gone through
something in their life,
get shameful that bad
things happen to them.
It's not really your fault,
it's out of your control
unless you're an addict taking pills,
you know it's your fault,
you just need the support.
And that's what I've been
lacking my whole life,
is outside support
'cause I've just had me.
And now that I have it,
it's such a difference.
I tried rejecting it at first
'cause that's what people do
but once you accept it and
you know your boundaries
and you learn yourself and how
you can function with others
without being scared of your past traumas,
it really does help people.
Especially if you've never gone through it
you can see a different
change with someone
once you've resolved or
at least got some closure
to something that's been bugging them.
- [Interviewer] With therapy.
- With what?
- Oh yeah, therapy or even
just talking to a friend
and actually having a
real sit-down not like,
oh my God, that's so funny, LMA, whatever.
Having a real sit down with people
and just talking, like
communicating not with a phone
which is so hard during COVID.
And that's why so many other
people are having depression
and families are arguing and
I've seen so many TikToks
with people just like,
"Yay, my mom's abusive again
"'cause I moved back."
I'm like, (sighs) "I
understand it completely."
And that's something that I
hate that I can understand,
is I know if I ever have a kid
is that that's never gonna happen,
is that unwanted feeling
or that just fear.
And that's where a lot of
people can empathize with me,
is that they don't
respect a lot of people,
they fear a lot of people
just because you can't
gain fear with respect.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think the difference is
between people who
end up broken from the
childhoods like yours
and people like yourself who maybe
have climbed out of it
and become stronger?
- The worst-case scenario
that I've just seen
are serial killers happen.
And if you look at them, they're way high.
But if you look at them as
the worst-case scenario,
they've been through troubled childhood.
Some have not, but a lot
of people who do crimes
or even kill others have such emotional,
like emotions just bottled up
from their emotional abuse and trauma.
And I've looked at so many people,
they wouldn't have done
drugs if they didn't have
this influencer there, or this stressor.
And it's just so much because
it's right then and there.
And if you can't reach
out 'cause you're shameful
or you don't know that it's
this traumatic for you,
you're gonna do something
stupid by all means.
Or you're gonna end up like me hopefully.
Or you're gonna be lost for a while.
And it does feel really
harsh to just not really
know what you're doing,
kind of learning yourself.
And that's why I did all of last year,
is I would just cry and cry.
Even when I started here, I'd just cry
because life is so hard.
But I wasn't reaching
out like I thought I was
until somebody said, "You
haven't talked to me,
"why didn't you reach out?"
I'm like, "Oh gosh," I was
like, "because I'm depressed."
What am I supposed to do?
And once I can joke
about it and get over it
and even realize what I'm doing,
like transparency with people,
at least I can handle it
as people will be like, "You're
depressed, get out of bed."
I'll be like, "Oh, you're right."
But some people really
need that support system
that I never had or
that I was that person,
but never got it back.
And so with that, it's just
there's so many different ways
people could end up because
if you let it prolong
and you don't actually
acknowledge the problems
or you don't cope with it
and your body just one day,
you get mad cause you
can't close a drawer.
And you're mad about
everything last past 20 years.
That's a worst-case scenario
for a normal person,
but then there's serial
killers or even people
who kill themselves
because it's just so much.
And mental health, at least
right now I've noticed,
it's just not taken seriously anymore.
'Cause everyone has
depression, everyone has this,
everyone's having problems
but it's just because
we have literally no
support system during COVID.
We're all locked away from each other,
and people don't wanna be
on their phones as much
'cause that's all we have is
to connect with each other.
And I think this last
year and still going on
is gonna be the hardest mentally at least
'cause no person expected a pandemic,
no one expected to change their life
or go back to an old life
they had abandoned like I did.
And it's so hard, especially since
everyone's going through this nationwide.
And at least for me, I know
I have cried multiple times
from it and I've stressed,
cried, just screamed in my car
and just had moments
where I'm like, "Why?"
And it's just the support
system I think people need
to either end up on a
really outbursts spectrum
of a meltdown or a more calm burnout.
And that's where I think
everyone was this year,
is just burnt out, too much
working, too little working.
It was just so much stress.
Everyone had to change their life
for either the best or
the worst at the time.
And that's all we had to deal with,
and it was out of our control.
And at least with me, I
know that I can empathize
with people during COVID
because it is so much
and it's so beautiful
just to like, oh gosh,
with someone I'd never
think that I would be
sympathizing and empathizing with
actually turn into a
really good friend of mine.
And they may have followers,
thousands of followers,
and just because I reached out
one day and this one follower
just had a feeling that they were not okay
and now we're friends and it's like,
wow, we really don't reach
out as much as we do.
And that's where the
shame just comes back in.
And once you just literally take it off,
it's literally just like a cloak,
you just take it off and it's gone.
That's why I have no shame at my doors,
no shame in my car, no shame anywhere.
You shouldn't have shame for anything
unless you're doing something wrong.
And that's at least what I felt growing up
and probably how everyone feels as well.
- [Interviewer] All right, Raven.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story,
very interesting.
- Yeah, thank you
for having me.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.